ja schönen guten Tag meine Damen und
Herren hier aus dem Reichstag aus der
Fraktionsebene ich stehe hier direkt
neben der Kuppel und die meisten
Fraktionssitzungen laufen ja in diesem
Moment bereits und natürlich spielt das
Ereignis von gestern die Hauptrolle das
Entlastungspaket was die Ampel geschnürt
hat und sie können sich vorstellen dass
die Bewertung über dieses Paket sehr
unterschiedlich sind zwischen den drei
ampelfraktionen auf der einen Seite und
den drei Oppositionsfraktionen auf der
anderen Seite es gibt ja auch noch
andere Player von außen die dieses Paket
bereits bewertet haben und wir werden
sicherlich die gesamte Woche nicht nur
während der haushaltswoche über die
Folgen dieses Paketes reden
Entlastungspaket heißt es 65 Milliarden
Euro soll es schwer sein die Frage wie
es denn genau finanziert wird wie denn
genau die Belastung aussieht die ist die
Ampel gestern schuldig geblieben das
liegt unter anderem daran zum Beispiel
beim Nachfolger des neuen eurotickets
dass da die Einzelheiten noch gar nicht
jetzt sind man muss den anderen Player
in diesem Falle eben die Bundesländer
mit ins Boot bringen die sind wenig im
News der Bund stellt Geld zur Verfügung
nun sollen sie auch Geld zur Verfügung
stellen die Grünen jedenfalls gehen
davon aus dass der Nachfolger bei 49
Euro rauskommen wird aber ob es denn
wirklich so kommen wird das ist die
Frage und dann steht heute noch auf dem
politischen Programm hier neben den
Fraktionssitzungen die Auswertung des
Stresstests die Grünen haben sich ja
lange dagegen gewehrt haben einen
zweiten Stresstest den Auftrag gegeben
genauer gesagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und der wird
heute Abend um 18 Uhr dieses Ergebnis
verraten was wird aus den drei
Atomkraftwerken und das werden Sie
natürlich bei uns auch hier live sehen
können doch zunächst widmen wir uns hier
den Fraktionen und Rolf Mützenich ist
der SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende er gerade
aus dem Urlaub zurückgekehrt war an dem
Paket nicht so maßgeblich beteiligt wie
die Parteivorsitzenden zum Beispiel und
hat aber bei dem Koalitionsausschuss
ebenfalls diese 22 Stunden natürlich mit
beraten und er war am Schluss Beratungen
bzw heute vor seiner Fraktionssitzung
sehr zufrieden mit dem was da gestern
ausgehandelt wurde
wir haben in der Tat in dieser Woche die
haushaltswoche so dass die
Fraktionssitzung auch an einem Montag
stattfinden wird gleich um 18 Uhr ich
will der Diskussion dort auch nicht
vorgreifen aber ich habe schon den
Eindruck aus Rückmeldungen von Seiten
mehrere fraktionskolleginnen und
Fraktionskollegen die sich sehr darüber
gefreut haben dass im
Koalitionsausschuss auch wenn es etwas
länger gedauert hat gute Beschlüsse
gefasst worden sind die natürlich jetzt
in ihrer größeren Zahl natürlich auch
parlamentarisch in Gesetze umgesetzt
werden muss es hat haushaltsrelevanz und
viele andere Dinge auch die jetzt meine
Fraktion sehr auch noch mal zusätzlich
zu den anderen Fragen arbeitsintensiv
beschäftigen werden aber das ist keine
Erschwernis sondern eine Freude weil wir
offensichtlich schon gesehen haben dass
das was die Fraktion in der Sommerpause
vorbereitet hat ohne dass sie jeden Tag
neue Themen hier genannt hat ein
umfangreiches Papier in der vergangenen
Woche veröffentlicht hat und man sich
durchaus auch in vielen dieser Punkte
wiederfindet und nicht sogar eher den
Eindruck habe dass viele sie auch an dem
Papier abgearbeitet hatten und zwar
wichtig gewesen dass wir verschiedene
Bereiche dort fassen Einmalzahlungen
auch für Rentnerinnen und Rentner für
Studierende aber eben auch für
Auszubildende das ist wichtig wir haben
auf der anderen Seite eben auch noch
eine Unterstützung für diejenigen die
finanziell sehr stark unter diesen
Herausforderungen sich auch
berechtigterweise Sorgen machen wir
wollen gleichzeitig aber auch und das
haben wir immer gesagt für die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer bei
der Progression das was an
Tarifverträgen besser gestellt ist auch
letztlich schützen
und zum anderen für uns natürlich
vielleicht für andere weniger wichtig
ein systemische
Verankerung von
Gesetzen nämlich soziale Rechte die dann
auch einklagbar sind sowohl was die
Frage eben eines größeren Kreises von
wohngeldempfängern betrifft aber auch
das Bürgergeld was wir auf den Weg
bringen wollen und dann dass es uns eben
glaube ich
gelingt auch im politischen Diskurs eine
Diskussion mit
[Musik]
anstreben die darauf nämlich hindeutet
dass der Markt nicht alles richten kann
sondern im Gegenteil dass der Staat dort
eingreifen muss wo Mechanismen Versagen
selbst gewählte Mechanismen und das
betrifft zum Beispiel eben den Eingriff
in den Strommarkt wo einige Unternehmen
unverdient große Gewinne einfahren weder
mit unternehmerischer Initiative noch
mit klugen Erfindungen letztlich dies
dann auch verdienen und diese
unverdienten Gewinne wollen wir
abgreifen und den Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher direkt zur Verfügung stellen
indem sie eben dann hier in einem
gewissen
grundkontingents günstiger Strom
beziehen kann und wir wollen das auch
darauf will ich noch mal ausdrücklich
hinweisen versuchen auch für andere
Bereiche des wärmemarktes jetzt zu
entwickeln und hier sollen zeitnah dann
auch Vorschläge erarbeitet werden ja
vielleicht so viel zur Einführung die
kommerziellen Fragen Herr Rinke
bei der strompreisbremse und diese
Abschöpfung der zufallsgewinne oder
übergewinne gibt es ja zwei
Stellschrauben nämlich einmal wie sie
diesen Grundbedarf definieren und
zweitens wo sie die Preisgrenze ansetzen
werden Sie dafür dass man das möglichst
niedrig oder möglichst hoch ansetzt in
der Ring ist es vollkommen richtig aber
ich glaube darauf noch mal auch Hinweis
nicht so wollen und auch zu müssen das
jetzt erstmal alle Anstrengungen
unternommen werden dass man das auf
europäische Ebene so schnell wie möglich
macht wir haben ja in den letzten Tagen
gesehen dass die Kommission das überlegt
weil viele europäische Regierung der
Auffassung sind das ist der richtige Weg
einige sind ja auch beim Gasmarkt schon
vorangegangen und die Bundesregierung
sollte das auf jeden Fall sehr stark mit
begleiten weil für mich sind europäische
Lösungen der beste Weg wenn es dazu
kommt brauchen wir kein nationalen Weg
zu gehen wenn wir den aber gehen müssen
dann möchte ich natürlich schon dass ich
das an einem durchschnittlichen
Verbrauch von Familien eben orientiert
was das betrifft darüber gibt es zahlen
und was ganz wichtig ist dass das was
abgegriffen wird dann eben auch den zur
Verfügung gestellt wird um am Ende
insgesamt auch zu günstigeren
Strompreisen zu kommen wir wollen ja
auch zum für dieses Geld nutzen das den
Verbraucherinnen und Verbrauchern
Menschen in Deutschland auch
zurückzugeben und ich finde das ein sehr
klugen weg und das wird die SPD-Fraktion
wenn ich schon genügend Konzepte dazu
vorlegen auch mit eigenem Sachverstand
in den Gesetzgebungsverfahren dann noch
anreichern das Ergebnis des zweiten
Stresstests wird in Kürze vorgestellt
wäre bei einer entsprechenden
Einschätzung aus Sicht von deiner Sicht
ein streckbetrieb mehrere AKW
vorstellbar oder ein Betrieb mit neuen
Brennstäben nun ich bin ganz gespannt
was der Wirtschaftsminister ich glaube
es ist heute abend
aufgrund der des oder der Gutachten auch
bekanntgeben wird und Welt zu welcher
politischen Entscheidung er sich dann
durchringt von daher werden wir das dann
bewerten wenn der Wirtschaftsminister
seine Vorstellungen und diese Ergebnisse
des stresste auch der Öffentlichkeit
bekannt gegeben hat
ja und das wird Robert Habeck ich habe
schon gesagt um 18 Uhr heute abend
erledigen die Ergebnisse des Stresstests
bekanntgeben werden die Atomkraftwerke
die drei die noch am Netz sind
weiterlaufen werden sie in einen
strickbetrieb gehen werden Sie in
Bereitschaft gehalten diese Frage wird
der Wirtschaftsminister heute Abend
sicherlich beantworten Saskia esken
übrigens die SPD-Parteivorsitzende hat
bei ihrer Pressekonferenz heute gesagt
also im Notfall eben dann ein
streckbetrieb für diese AKWs aber auf
keinen Fall darüber hinausgehend etwas
mit neuen Brennstäben etc da gibt es
also Widerstand bei der Linken in der
SPD und natürlich bei den Bündnisgrünen
da geht es ja ums Eingemachte zurück zur
Atomkraft ein Horror für jeden grünen
dennoch muss man natürlich als Politiker
dann den Menschen erklären warum sie in
ihren Wohnungen frieren sollen wenn die
drei AKWs im Moment doch acht bis zehn
Millionen Wohnungen mit Wärmeversorgung
könnten das ist dann schon die Frage die
man beantworten muss wo kommt diese
Energie sonst her und Quatsch was ich
gesagt habe nicht mit Wärme sondern mit
Strom weil die AKWs den Strom
produzieren und nicht die Wärme aber das
Wärmeprobleme übrigens ist auch ein ganz
wichtiges was gestern in dem Paket ja
nicht angesprochen wurde da hat man eine
Kommission gebildet der Gaspreis heute
bereits um 30 Prozent explodiert also da
müssen sich die Politiker noch was
einfallen lassen die Bündnis grüne
Britta Hasselmann ist eine von zwei
Fraktionsvorsitzenden ihrer Fraktion sie
jedenfalls ist sehr zufrieden vor allen
Dingen auch mit der Größe des Pakets
gestern 65 Milliarden Britta Hasselmann
nach dem Wochenende ist dann jetzt klar
wir haben ein drittes Entlastungspaket
in der Ampel vereinbart wo wir jetzt mit
Hochdruck an die Umsetzung gehen wir
haben ein großes Paket was 65 Milliarden
Euro umfasst und viele verschiedene
Maßnahmen beinhaltet die dazu beitragen
sollen dass in dieser Krisensituation in
der Energiepreise und Lebensmittelpreise
steigen in der viele Menschen Sorgen vor
Armut und Abstieg haben deutlich wird
wir gehen in dieser Zeit gemeinsam und
klar als Signal nach vorne dass wir hier
für soziale Abfederung sorgen und
gleichzeitig auch Signale in Richtung
der
fragestrommarktdesign der Frage
Klimaschutz
Patienten mit den Maßnahmen die wir
vereinbart haben dazu gehören unter
anderem die
Reform des Wohngeldes dazu gehören die
energiepreispauschale für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner für Studierende für
Fachschülerinnen dazu gehört klar die
Aussage dass wir uns um ein Moratorium
bei Strom und Gas sperren bemühen wollen
auch die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes und
des kinderzuschlages ist ein weiterer
Schritt in Richtung Kindergrundsicherung
und das Signal an Familien mit Kindern
wir sehen eure Belastung und leiten hier
entsprechende Schritte ein und nicht
zuletzt die Frage der Reform des
Bürgergeldes die wir im Parlament auch
noch weiter vertiefen werden aber mit
einem ersten Schritt auf die Erhöhung
der Regelsätze um circa 50 Euro auf 5
Euro ist glaube ich ein wichtiges
soziales signaler erfolgt auch im
Bereich der Frage wie können wir
eigentlich an so einer Stelle an der wir
über Krisen und Belastungen für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger reden auch
diejenigen Konzerne die
zufallsgewinne abschöpfen mit in die
Verantwortung nehmen haben wir ein
klares Signal geschickt denn das
entlassungspaket soll neben dem
Haushaltsmitteln über die es finanziert
werden soll auch über das abschöpfen von
zufallsgewinnen finanziert werden ich
glaube das ist ein wichtiges Signal auch
im Gerechtigkeitsempfinden der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bei viele der
Maßnahmen sind wir jetzt darauf
angewiesen sehr schnell in die Umsetzung
zu kommen damit auch spürbar wird wie
ernst es uns mit diesem dritten
Entlastungspaket ist alle weiteren
Arbeiten werden wir jetzt zwischen
Parlament und Bundesregierung abstimmen
und auf den Weg bringen an dieser Stelle
auch eine Fortsetzung des neuen
euro-tickets in Form eines weiteren
vergünstigten Tickets wollen wir
gemeinsam mit den Ländern auf den Weg
bringen hier ist ein Ticket
im Angebotsbereich von 49 bis 69 Euro
vereinbart worden wir gehen davon aus
dass in Gesprächen mit den Ländern und
durch die Finanzmittel die wir zur
Verfügung stellen wollen ein 49 Euro
Ticket sich realisiert was ein sehr
wichtiges Signal und Schritt wäre im
Bereich der Mobilität zusätzlich haben
wir noch 1,5 Milliarden Millionen
Milliarden Euro
festgelegt im Bereich Verkehr in dem wir
auf den Ausbau der Schiene und die Frage
der Reduzierung der CO2-Emissionen in
diesem Bereich setzen alles in allem ist
es ein klares Signal dass wir hier
zielgenau dass wir hier nachhaltig
entlasten wollen und ich glaube dieses
Signal wird auch als ein solches
verstanden wir werden in dieser Woche
den Haushalt anbraten und auch im Rahmen
des Haushaltes werden wir über die
Akzente der Ampel im Bereich der
ökologischen und sozialen Transformation
der notwendigen weiteren Bekämpfung der
Klimakrise der Biodiversität der
Agrarwende wenn ich an die
tierhaltungskennzeichnung denke und
viele viele Bereiche im Bereich Soziales
Gesundheit erfassen hier ist es ganz
wichtig auch das Signal aus dem
Entlastungspaket am Wochenende sich
darauf verständigt zu haben dass wir im
Bereich der globalen Ernährung
zusätzlich eine Milliarde Euro
bereitstellen wollen um Fragen der
globalen Ernährung der humanitären Hilfe
und Krisenbewältigung auch im globalen
Süden zu verstärken all das wird jetzt
natürlich während der
haushaltsplanberatung des Parlamentes
Thema werden uns ist es wichtig die
zeitenwände die Krisensituation nicht
nur durch konkrete
Entlastungsmaßnahmen wie im dritten
Entlastungspaket abzufedern sondern auch
durch Akzente im Haushalt die deutlich
unterstreichen die zeitenwände wird
nachhaltig und sozial gestaltet also
Britta Hasselmann und die Bündnisgrünen
sind zufrieden dabei muss die
co2-bepreisung die eigentlich zum ersten
Januar steigen sollte um 5 Euro pro
Tonne erst einmal ein Jahr verschoben
werden aber das sind wahrscheinlich nur
Kleinigkeiten in diesem Zusammenhang
auch die FDP ist sehr zufrieden denn man
glaubt es kaum 65 Milliarden soll das
Paket schwer sein und der
Bundesfinanzminister hat es gestern
mehrfach ausgeführt er hat vieles vorher
eingestellt er muss keine neuen Schulden
aufnehmen und hält damit die
Schuldenbremse und das war ihm wohl am
wichtigsten und auch Christian dürr der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP hat genau
darauf hingewiesen
sie wissen dass die Koalition der
Koalitionsausschuss am Wochenende getagt
hat in einer längeren Sitzung das ist
leider nötig geworden auf der einen
Seite was die Zeit betrifft auf der
anderen Seite war es richtig und gut
dass wir so lange zusammengekommen sind
denn das Ergebnis kann sich sehen lassen
es ist ein schlagkräftiges Paket für
Deutschland ein Entlastungspaket was ich
glaube auch im europäischen Vergleich
seinesgleichen sucht auch wenn die
Sitzung etwas länger gedauert hat und
bis in die tiefen Morgenstunden ging war
das Ergebnis auf jeden Fall eines was
der Mühe wert war wir schaffen das war
ja der Ausgangspunkt ein wuchtigen
Aufschlag an dieser Stelle denn wir
wollen dass Deutschland gut gerüstet ist
für Herbst und Winter einerseits was das
ökonomische betrifft und andererseits
natürlich was die Energieversorgung in
Deutschland betrifft ich will kurz zu
den Punkten etwas sagen der wichtigste
Punkt aus Sicht der Freien Demokraten
ist natürlich die steuerliche Entlastung
der hart arbeiten Mitte in Deutschland
das sind die einigen die 48 Millionen
einkommensteuerzahlerinnen und
einkommensteuerzahler die das Land auch
wirtschaftlich tragen und gerade in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten brauchen
diesen Menschen Entlastung und es darf
natürlich nicht so sein dass durch die
hohen Inflation in Deutschland in Europa
diese hart arbeitende Mitte zusätzlich
belastet wird und deswegen hat ja der
Bundesfinanzminister bereits vor einiger
Zeit ein
inflationsausgleichsgesetz vorgestellt
das hat der Koalitionsausschuss so
übernommen und noch etwas hinzugefügt
denn es wird ein Update des
progressionsberichts und des sogenannten
existenzminimumsberichts geben das heißt
es wird noch einmal dieser
Inflationsausgleich an die aktuelle
Inflationsrate angeglichen und insofern
bin ich froh dass das unsere Partner
mittragen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich aber es ist ganz
wichtig für die hart arbeitende Mitte
und darüber freue ich mich sehr wir
werden Unterstützung für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner auf den Weg geben bringen
die 300 Euro über die viel gesprochen
worden ist wir werden Unterstützung für
die Studierenden auf den Weg bringen 200
Euro an der Stelle diese Einmalzahlung
sind gerade für diejenigen die nicht so
viel Geld im Monat übrig haben sehr sehr
wichtig und deswegen unterstützen wir
auch das es wird eine wohngeldreform
geben für Deutschland für die Freien
Demokraten war das Wohngeld immer das
Beste sozialpolitische Instrument in der
Wohnungsbaupolitik und wir werden die
midijob-grenze anheben das ist gerade
wichtig für den sozialen Aufstieg von
Menschen und auch das findet unsere
uneingeschränkte Unterstützung gerade im
unteren Einkommensbereich eben Menschen
entsprechend zu entlasten die sehr hart
arbeiten ich freue mich dass es auch
eine Einigung gibt für eine Fortführung
eines digitalen deutschlandtickets
Volker Wissing hat ja in den letzten
Wochen sehr hart daran gearbeitet das 9
euro-ticket auf den Weg zu bringen das
ist alles andere als selbstverständlich
und gerade zu einer Revolution für den
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr in
Deutschland und jetzt schaffen wir es
dass auch bundesweit sozusagen auf
Maschine zu bringen und das ist ein
gutes Zeichen nun sind die Bundesländer
gefragt hier mitzumachen es gibt in
Deutschland eine Vielzahl von
Verkehrsverbünden es gibt eine Vielzahl
von Tickets man schätzt das allein die
Vermarktung dieser Tickets schon jedes
Jahr über zwei Milliarden Euro kostet
diese Bürokratiekosten müssen runter das
muss in den ÖPNV investiert werden und
ich hoffe und baue darauf dass die
Bundesländer hier mithelfen der Bund
wird sein finanziellen Teil dazu tragen
auch das haben wir im
Koalitionsausschuss beschlossen und das
ist dann eben auch der Startpunkt für
ein digitales deutschlandticket ich habe
vorhin gesagt dass eine sind die
Entlastung das andere ist das was wir
auch energiepolitisch tun müssen die
stark gestiegenen Strompreise versetzen
zurecht die privaten Haushalte und auch
die Unternehmen in Deutschland in Sorge
denn so hohe Strompreise kann kein
privater Haushalt kann kein Unternehmen
in Deutschland tragen dauerhaft und
deswegen müssen wir hier direkt am Markt
ansetzen und da ist das was wir im
Koalitionsausschuss besprochen haben
dass wir hier an die Preisbildung an den
Markt gehen der Markt hat ja ganz
unnatürlich und auch
unmarktwirtschaftliche Preise auf der
einen Seite durch die das hohe Gas die
hohen Gaspreise natürlich eine ein hoher
Strompreis bei der Verstromung von Gas
und dieser Preis überträgt sich auch auf
die anderen Erzeugungsarten die dadurch
zusätzliche Erlöser haben und diese
Zusatzerlöse sind ungerechtfertigt das
hat nichts mit Risikobereitschaft oder
besonders neue Technologie zu tun
sondern ist wirklich ein zufallserlös
und der sollte begrenzt werden wichtig
ist für uns dass wir natürlich an der
Schuldenbremse festhalten was kein
ökonomisches Dogma ist sondern ein
ökonomisches Gebot in diesen Tagen die
Schuldenbremse ist derzeit auch eine
inflationsbremse denn wenn der Staat
ausufern Schulden machen würde expansiv
unterwegs wäre dann würde insbesondere
die Inflation zusätzlich angeheizt und
das wiederum würde die privaten
Haushalte und die Unternehmen
belastenden eine geltentwertung kann
dieser Tage eine weitere Geldentwertung
kann wirklich niemand brauchen insofern
ist die das Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse auch ein Gebot angesichts
der steigenden Inflation in Deutschland
und zum dritten will ich ansprechen das
Thema Energieversorgung und insbesondere
Versorgungssicherheit über die Preise
habe ich bereits gerade einiges gesagt
im dritten Entlastungspaket haben wir
uns damit intensiv
auseinandergesetzt aber es muss auch das
Ziel sein dass wir die
Versorgungssicherheit aber auch die
Preise stabil halten durch eine
Ausweitung des Angebots also neben der
Frage des stromagdesigns geht es aus
auch darum dass Angebot so auszuweiten
dass der Preis nach unten geht der sehr
hohe Preis am Strommarkt ist zurzeit
einerseits sein Grund ist zu suchen im
Strommarkt Design und auf der anderen
Seite natürlich auch ein sehr knappen
Angebot ist ein knappheitssignal und
deswegen das wissen sie ist die FDP sehr
offen dafür dass die drei noch am Netz
Bef Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland über
den 31.12 hinaus betrieben werden können
und als Fraktion haben wir in der
vergangenen Woche auch ein
Positionspapier beschlossen indem wir
empfehlen dass auch über den Kauf neuer
Brennstäbe gesprochen wird denn das wird
wäre ein deutliches marktsignal dass an
der Stelle eben auch mehr Strom zur
Verfügung steht und das würde die Preise
noch einmal zusätzlich nach unten
bringen hier erwarten wir ja im Laufe
des heutigen Abends auch das Ergebnis
des Stresstest dass dann der
bundeswirtschafts- und Energieminister
entsprechend vorstellen wird
die FDP also für eine Verlängerung der
Laufzeiten der AKWs das ist nichts neues
das hat ihr Vorsitzender Christian
Lindner schon seit geraumer Zeit zu
vertreten in der jetzigen Lage sei es
nicht realistisch Atomkraftwerke vom
Netz gehen zu lassen am 31.12 und am
ersten dann plötzlich 6% weniger bei der
Stromerzeugung zu haben die man dann
auch über Kohlekraftwerke zum Beispiel
produzieren müsste so die Argumentation
der FDP wir werden ja sehen was der
Stresstest des grünen
Wirtschaftsministers Robert Habeck heute
Abend dazu ergibt 65 Milliarden und
keine neuen Schulden das liegt auch
daran dass die Hälfte dieses Paketes
unter anderem von den Ländern finanziert
werden soll und auch durch diese
sogenannten zufallsgewinne das Geld ist
also noch gar nicht da aber den Bürgern
quasi schon versprochen nun ja Friedrich
Merz der Oppositionsführer der CDU-Chef
hat gestern in einem großen Interview ja
dazu gesagt das hört sich viel an 65
Milliarden aber der Staat ist ja einer
der Kinder durch die Mehrwertsteuer
innimmt viel ein in Größenordnung von 60
Milliarden ergibt das Geld da quasi nur
an die Bürger zurück dennoch ist es für
ein Oppositionsführer nicht leicht
dieses Paket zu kritisieren zumal die
Ampel auch das ein oder andere Element
der unionsvorschläge übernommen hat wie
Friedrich Merz eben hier vor der
Fraktionssitzung auch noch einmal
feststellte wir beraten in dieser Woche
in erster Lesung den Bundeshaushalt 2023
neben dem Bundeshaushalt stehen
natürlich die Fragen der
Energieversorgungssicherheit und der
wirtschaftlichen Lage unseres Landes
ebenso wie die Lage der privaten
Haushalte im Vordergrund wir haben uns
in der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
intensiv vorbereitet auf diese Woche sie
wissen dass wir in der letzten Woche mit
dem geschäftsführenden Fraktionsvorstand
zwei Tage in Klausur getagt haben und
dort eine Reihe von Vorschlägen
erarbeitet haben wie wir mit diesem
Problem umgehen würden wir haben dann
über das Wochenende von der
Bundesregierung die Vorschläge erhalten
wie sie meint die Probleme des Landes in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen lösen zu
können wir begrüßen ausdrücklich dass
die Bundesregierung auf eine ganze Reihe
von Vorschlägen eingegangen ist und sie
übernommen hat die wir unterbreitet
haben ich nenne beispielhaft nur den
Vorschlag der Bundesregierung jetzt auch
die Rentnerinnen und Rentner an der
Umlage oder an der Zahlung von 300 Euro
zu beteiligen die Studierenden ebenfalls
in Höhe von wenigstens 200 wenn man
diesen Weg schon geht sie wissen dass
wir das nicht unkritisch sehen mit der
Gießkanne hier für alle 300 Euro
auszuzahlen aber wenn man diesen Weg
schon geht dann ist es richtig auch die
Rentnerhaushalte und die Studierenden
daran zu beteiligen wir sehen eine ganze
Reihe von anderen Vorschlägen über die
man diskutieren kann unsere generelle
Einschätzung der Vorschläge ist erstens
sie sind zu unpräzise sie verschieben
teilweise auch die Lösung der Probleme
auf Expertenkommissionen die jetzt alle
noch Tagen sollen das hätte man alles im
Sommer schon längst machen können wir
sind jetzt immerhin im siebten Monat
dieses Krieges und damit im siebten
Monat dieser Krise die Bundesregierung
hat wieder einmal über den Sommer
wertvollste Zeit verstreichen lassen
ohne zu Entscheidungen zu kommen sie
wissen dass wir der Bundesregierung auch
angeboten haben im Sommer eine
Sondersitzung des Deutschen Bundestages
in Fragen der Kernenergie durchzuführen
auch dieses Angebot hat die
Bundesregierung nicht angenommen im
Gegenteil es fehlt in den Beschlüssen
vom gestrigen Tag jeder Hinweis auf die
Frage wie denn die Energieversorgung des
Landes sichergestellt werden kann auf
der Angebotsseite die Angebotsseite
heißt eine Reaktion eine angemessene
Reaktion auf den angebotsschock den es
gibt durch die Verknappung der
Gaslieferungen aus Russland und wie wir
soeben erfahren haben wird ja jetzt Nord
Stream 1 endgültig gekappt wird nicht
mehr geliefert über Nord Stream 1 ich
sag mal in Klammern hinzu ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass sowohl die deutsche
Wirtschaft als auch die deutsche
Bundesregierung gegen diese Propaganda
der letzten Tage die davon der
russischen Seite vorgetragen worden ist
im Hinblick auf angebliche Leckagen der
Pipeline energischer vorgegangen wäre
dem energischer widersprochen hätte hier
regiert offensichtlich Angst das Handeln
der Bundesregierung aber auch Teile der
deutschen Industrie das hätte man viel
klarer und viel deutlicher zum Ausdruck
bringen sollen es ist reine Propaganda
aber zurück zur der eigentlichen
Fragestellung wie begegnet man diesem
angebotsschock wenn man sieht dass das
Angebot zu knapp wird dann darf man sich
nicht erst mit den Fragen beschäftigen
wie man die Betroffenen entschädigt
sondern da muss man sich zuerst mit der
Frage auseinandersetzen wie erhöht man
das Angebot und auch dazu haben wir sehr
konkrete Vorschläge unterbreitet einen
Vorschlag haben wir bereits lange vor
der Sommerpause der Bundesregierung
gemacht nämlich aus Biomasse die
Verstromung unbegrenzt zuzulassen die
Bundesregierung hat das zugesagt ein
konkreter Gesetzentwurf fehlt bis heute
der Bundesregierung vorgeschlagen die
Laufzeit der Kernkraftwerke zu
verlängern ein Vorschlag fehlt bis heute
wir haben der Bundesregierung gesagt sie
soll eine Belastungsanalyse machen sie
soll einen Stresstest machen das
Ergebnis sollte angeblich am letzten
Mittwoch vorgelegt werden feststehen das
Ergebnis fehlt bis heute wir wissen
nicht welche Grundlagen welche
Datengrundlagen die Bundesregierung
zugrunde liegt um jetzt auch den
Strombedarf zu ermitteln unsere
Auffassung dürfen wir jetzt auf keine
Option der Energieerzeugung auch auf
keine Option der Stromerzeugung in
Deutschland verzichten denn nur so
können wir einigermaßen sicher sein dass
wir eine zu erwartende Stromlücke nicht
in dem Umfang erleben dass es zu
Blackouts in Deutschland kommt ich
fordere die Bundesregierung jetzt noch
mal auf wirklich die Laufzeit der
wenigstens der drei noch am Netz
befindlichen Kernkraftwerke über den
Jahreswechsel
2022/2023 hinaus zu verlängern
Brennstäbe bestellen zu lassen das
Atomgesetz zu ändern und die Laufzeit
dieser Kernkraftwerke zu ermöglichen es
ist international wird mit völliger
Verständnislosigkeit begegnet das was da
jetzt in Deutschland gegenwärtig hier
diskutiert wird wir brauchen diese
Kraftwerke damit wir wirklich Strom
erzeugen immerhin für 10 Millionen
Haushalte aus diesen drei
Kernkraftwerken wir werden alle diese
Themen in der kommenden Woche die jetzt
vor uns liegt Ansprechen im Rahmen der
Haushaltsberatungen wir werden uns
natürlich auch mit den Haushaltszahlen
auseinandersetzen aber das wichtigste
ist dass die Bevölkerung das auch die
Betriebe in Deutschland einigermaßen
sicher sein können dass im Rahmen des
Möglichen geholfen wird in den nächsten
Tagen Wochen und Monaten ich sage das
ausdrücklich nicht nur für die privaten
Haushalte sondern auch für die Betriebe
insbesondere die kleinen und mittleren
Betriebe die sich vollkommen allein
gelassen fühlen durch die deutsche
Politik wir brauchen hier stärkere klar
bessere Klarheit stärkere Unterstützung
auch Klarheit in der Energieversorgung
und damit sich sozusagen der Kreis es
geht nicht nur darum jetzt noch mehr
Geld zu bezahlen sondern es geht vor
allem darum die Angebotslücke zu
schließen die durch den russischen Krieg
in der Ukraine und durch die Verknappung
des Gases entstanden ist hier handelt
die Bundesregierung nicht entschlossen
genug ich will sie noch einmal
auffordern wir reichen die Hand dazu
dass auch gemeinsam zu tun dass
Atomgesetz zu ändern andere
Rechtsgrundlagen zu ändern bis hin zur
gasumlage wir haben den Antrag
eingebracht in den Deutschen Bundestag
die gasumlage aufzuheben daraus wird
nichts mehr die wird auch nicht besser
wenn Sie jetzt nachgebessert wird das
ist der falsche Weg wenn man die
systemrelevanten Unternehmen schützen
will vor Insolvenzen dann muss man das
auf die Unternehmen konzentrieren es
gibt Beispiele dafür wir haben das mal
in der Bankenkrise gesehen wie man das
machen kann wir haben das in der Krise
gesehen um die Lufthansa wie man das
machen kann im Übrigen bleibt uns die
Bundesregierung jede Transparenz
schuldig wie sie denn eigentlich diese
Umlage berechnet hat sie hat zugesagt
und heute nicht eingehalten und deswegen
sagen wir weg mit dieser Umlage hin zu
einem Schutz der systemrelevanten
Unternehmen und nicht eine gasumlage
deren Erträge noch vereinnahmt werden
von Unternehmen die sie nun wirklich
nicht brauchen diese Umlage ist ein
Fehler und dieser Fehler muss aufgehoben
werden der Deutsche Bundestag wird in
dieser Woche Gelegenheit haben dass
durch eine Abstimmung auch entsprechend
zum Ausdruck zu bringen vielen Dank
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
bereits einem Tag nachdem die Ampel ihr
kompromiss-paket verkündet hat wird klar
dass dieses Paket nicht nur unkonkret
sondern auch unvollständig und
ungenügend ist wir leben gerade heute
wieder ein Rekordpreis eine
rekordpreisentwicklung beim Gas und eine
erhebliche Verteuerung der Energie
dieses Kompromisspaket der Ampel gibt
darauf keine ausreichende Antwort über
die Fragen der Kapazitäten ist darüber
darin nichts zu finden und die Gefahr
ist groß dass ohne massive
angebotssteigerung bei der Energie aus
der Energiekrise eine veritable
Wirtschaft oder auch sozialkrise wird
soweit also Alexander Dobrindt Friedrich
Merz hat es angekündigt die Union wird
einen Antrag vorlegen gegen die
gaspreisumlage
dieser haushaltswoche denn daran sei
noch mal erinnert der Bundestag befindet
sich in einer haushaltswoche der
Haushalt
445,2 Milliarden Euro schwer und
Christian Lindner ist sehr zufrieden er
hatte vorgesorgt und hat gesagt er muss
keine neuen Schulden aufnehmen für das
große Paket was da gestern verabschiedet
wurde zwischen den ampelparteien 65
Milliarden schwer ein großer Fehler ist
dieses gesamte Paket das meint die AFD
und ihre beiden parteivor bzw
Fraktionsvorsitzenden sind hier vorhin
auch vor die Presse gegangen
ganz oben auf der politischen Agenda ist
das Entlastungspaket
was ein wahrliches Demokratie
Bürokratiemonster ist und
das
entlassungspaket ist mit 65 Milliarden
angesetzt wo nur die Hälfte finanziert
ist die andere Hälfte das müssen erstmal
abwarten wo das überhaupt herkommen soll
und wie immer dass bei der Umverteilung
ist es muss
querfinanziert werden nicht warm also
was heute entlastet wird wird morgen
belastet warum man dieses Paket auch ein
Belastungspaket nennen kann und es
steckt doch nicht alles ab es ist ein
Prinzip von einwandtzahlung
und das ist natürlich
hoch willkürlich verteilt
und die andere Schwäche des
Belastungspaket ist wenn sie einmal
damit anfangen werden die Forderungen
laut gleich nach dem dritten vierten
oder fünften und
der dritte Hinkefuß ist
das ist
strategisch nicht nach vorne geplant ist
es wirkt im Hier und Jetzt da muss man
ja auch die Regierung mal ausnahmsweise
loben dass sie jetzt mit notflästerchen
ankommt für das was seit Jahrzehnten
mittlerweile versäumt wurde aber
strategisch gesehen müssen wir die
Bürger ja entlasten und das geht eben
nur durch flächendeckende
Steuerreduktion darum fordert die
afd-fraktion ja schon seit seit jeher
die Abschaffung der CO2-Abgabe die
Aussetzung aller Mehrwertsteuern auf die
energiebepreis jeglicher Art und wir
müssen langfristig mit den Einkommen
Steuern und Sozialabgaben herunter und
das heißt dass wir hier auf der
Ausgabenseite des Haushaltes ran müssen
anstatt ein Bürokratiemonster nach dem
anderen zu schaffen was die Bürger
brauchen sind echte Entlastung ein Thema
was ja diese Woche auch auf der
Tagesordnung des Pläne besteht das ist
das leidige Thema Infektionsschutzgesetz
mit dem wir uns wieder behandeln müssen
wo wir alle schon dachten dass dieses
leidige Kapitel beendet ist das neue
Infektionsschutzgesetz ist wieder zu
einem Flickenteppich verschiedenster
Regeln in den Bundesländern verkommen
Bund hat hier wieder keine klaren Regeln
aufgestellt das Lauterbach auch mit
diesen widersinnigen diskriminierenden
und vor allen Dingen fallen faktisch
kaum durchführbaren Bestimmungen dieses
Gesetzes die Bürger sogar noch zum
drei-monats-impfabo nötigen darf treibt
die Irrationalität und auch die
bürgerverachtung der corona-politik
dieser Regierung wirklich auf die Spitze
Teilnahme am Gesellschaft geben
gesellschaftlichen Leben ohne Maske nur
noch für frisch geimpfte das ist
wirklich der Versuch die im Bundestag
hier mit klarer Mehrheit abgeschmetterte
Impfpflicht doch noch durch die
Hintertür einführen zu wollen ich würde
gerne mal wissen wenn Sie die wiederholt
die Öffnung von nordstream 2 fordern es
gibt den denn die Sicherheit dass dann
dort Gas fließen würde wenn es schon
durch Nord Stream Einsitz nicht fließt
ja also ich kann gerne beginnen also wir
müssen ja mal einfach an die
Ursachenforschung gehen und das ist ja
das was er an dem aktuellen den
aktuellen Diskussion überhaupt nicht
vorankommt den Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
Russland hat Robert Habig begonnen und
das ist nun die Gegenreaktion das jetzt
auch Russland wahrscheinlich die
Lieferung über Nord Stream 1 einstellt
und das ist genau der Punkt den wir
kritisieren dass wir endlich in unserem
Interessen dass wir eine Interessen
geleitete Außenpolitik in den
Vordergrund stellen müssen und keine
Werte geleitet werden ich denke das ist
wichtig wir müssen unsere eigenen
Interessen in den Vordergrund stellen
und das ist auch die Aufgabe der
Bundesregierung damit wir wieder günstig
Gas bekommen und das ist der erste
Aufgabe ja wenn ich danach fragen darf
also sie sagen jetzt quasi die Russen
sagen ja das nordstream 1 kaputt ist und
deswegen kein Gas dort kommt glauben sie
das gar nicht
wissen Sie was man glauben kann und
Glauben nicht ich würde gerne zum
Beispiel auch wissen was hat denn die
Bundesregierung was haben die
Unternehmen zum Beispiel in Russland an
Gas bestellt was vielleicht gar nicht
geliefert werden kann oder sollte also
das beantwortet die Bundesregierung zum
Beispiel überhaupt nicht wie sehen die
Lieferverträge aktuell aus wie sind die
Laufzeiten wir werden noch hier völlig
Unklaren gelassen und hat man wirklich
geglaubt dass man Sanktionen beschließen
kann auf europäischer Ebene wo sich ja
viele Länder im übrigen mittlerweile
auch eigene vertragliche Grundlagen
schaffen mit Russland dass man das hier
keine Gegenreaktion gibt das ist genau
dieser Wirtschaftskrieg von dem wir
immer gesprochen haben der jetzt diese
Eskalation weiter anheizt
Tino krupala mit seiner Sicht der Dinge
es fließt kein Gas mehr durch Nord
Stream 1 und da liegt es ja dann nah
dass der eine oder andere auf die Idee
kommt Nord Stream 2 könnte doch bedient
werden ob das die Russen wollen ob das
die Europäer wollen alles völlig
ungeklärt der Vorschlag ist ja auch
nicht neue Wolfgang Kubicki hatte das
Jahr von der FDP auch schon mal
angedacht wurde dann aber von den seinen
damit heftiger Kritik bedacht man muss
sich immer wieder in Erinnerung rufen wo
die Ursache des Problems liegt und die
ist der Überfall der Russen des
russischen Präsidenten genauer gesagt
auf die Ukraine und das sollte man an
dieser Stelle auch noch mal klar
unterstreichen ja wenn sie mitgezählt
haben dann fehlt noch eine Fraktion
nämlich die Linksfraktion und Dietmar
Bartsch der kurvorsitzende der Linken
hat hier vorhin vor seiner
Fraktionssitzung gesagt bei diesem Paket
was da gestern verabschiedet wurde unter
den ampelkoalitionären da handelt es
sich um einen scheinriesen und wir
wollen doch erstmal sehen wie viel von
diesen Maßnahmen a finanziert werden
können zum anderen wollen wir auch genau
wissen was an Entlastung für den
Einzelnen herauskommt denn das ist aus
dem Paket gar nicht heraus zu lesen
Dietmar bartschert auch angekündigt dass
die Bürger dass die Linke auch auf die
Straße gehen wird für warme Wohnungen
und für ein Leben dass ich auch arme
Menschen weiter in Deutschland leisten
können müssen so Dietmar Bartsch der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Linksfraktion
natürlich wird diese Sitzungswoche die
haushaltswoche sehr durch das
Entlastungspaket was am Wochenende
vorgestellt worden ist geprägt werden
der Haushalt der bisher vorgelegen hat
ist erstmal Makulatur und das wird alles
neu zu behandeln sein bin sehr gespannt
wie das dann im konkreten insbesondere
mit den eckwerken die Herr Linder
vorgegeben hat keine also die
Schuldenbremse wird eingehalten keine
Steuererhöhung wie man das alles
hinkriegen will ich will aber zunächst
noch mal auf den Sommer verweisen und
darauf hinweisen dass ein solches Chaos
wie es in diesem Sommer gegeben habe ich
selten erlebt habe
also die Ampel hat offensichtlich diese
Monate kaum genutzt wenn ich mir
anschaue das ganze Desaster um die
gaspreisumlage im mir anschaue das dann
plötzlich der Bundeskanzler sagt dass
die Mehrwertsteuer abgesenkt wird und
dass das sogar ausgleicht was aber die
Unwahrheit ist dann kann ich nur sagen
der Sommer hätte von dieser Ampel anders
genutzt werden müssen und man hätte auch
ein anderes Paket vorlegen müssen dieses
Paket ist der Lage dem Ernst der Lage
nicht angemessen es ist aus Sicht der
Linken unzureichend das dritte
Entlastungspaket klingt gut in der Summe
aber es handelt sich nach unserer
Überzeugung nach meiner Überzeugung um
einen scheinriesen die haben
scholzlinder und Habeck addiert
aber wenn man sich mal genau anschaut
was denn real für die Menschen passiert
da droht wirklich ein teuertornado da
droht auch wirklich Abfall vieler
Menschen in sozial sehr sehr
problematische Situationen das wird von
65 Milliarden geredet wenn ich genau
hinschaue sind das 32 Milliarden auf der
Bundesebene der Rest wird an die Länder
gehen selbst wenn ich diese 65 addiere
mit den 30 Milliarden der ersten beiden
Pakete ist es deutlich weniger als die
100 Milliarden die in einer Nacht von
Olaf Scholz beschlossen worden sind und
ARD als Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr verkündet hat das ist meines
Erachtens ein riesengroßer Widerspruch
und wenn man weiß dass allein die
Mehreinnahmen aus der Mehrwertsteuer in
diesem Jahr durch die gigantische
Inflation zwischen 50 und 60 Milliarden
betragen dann ist dieses Paket wirklich
unzureichend es ist insbesondere für
klein und Normalverdiener aus unserer
Sicht eine Luftnummer vielfach wird von
der einen Tasche in die andere
verteilt ja es gibt Dinge wo sich der
Druck hier im Parlament und auch der
Druck außerhalb des Parlaments
ausgezahlt hat Rentnerinnen und Rentner
bekommen jetzt die energiepreisumlage
von 300 Euro Studierende 200 Euro
immerhin es ist zwar nur ein Tropfen auf
den heißen inflationsstein aber es ist
immerhin eine Entscheidung wo nachgeholt
wird was lange von anderen auch von uns
hier im Deutschen Bundestag eingefordert
worden ist wenn ich mir die konkreten
Maßnahmen anschaue dann gibt es vielfach
große Enttäuschung für mich
steht ganz oben die größte Enttäuschung
die Kindergelderhöhung von 18 Euro das
muss man sich mal überlegen zum ersten
Januar 18 Euro sie wissen wie viel Stück
Butter das sind wenn man es umrechnet
sie wissen aber auch wie hoch die
Inflationsrate ist und diese 7,9% die es
im letzten Monat waren werden die
niedrigsten die im Vergleich zu den
nächsten Monaten sein völlig
inakzeptabel dass hier so Kinder
abgespeist werden von
Kindergrundsicherung bis heute keine
Spur und ich sage ganz klar die
Kindergrundsicherung ist ein Mittel
gegen Kinderarmut was jetzt hier
geleistet worden ist es wahrhaftig nicht
nur kein großer Wurf das ist überhaupt
kein Wurf gegen Kinderarmut aber ich
kann mir auch anschauen was denn
wirklich konkret gegen die teilweise
astronomischen Energiepreise getan wird
das ist absolut unzureichend die Ampel
wäre in der Sommerpause in der Pflicht
gewesen in diesen drei Monaten etwas
vorzulegen was wirklich zum Beispiel das
von uns geforderte kostengünstige
grundkontingent betrifft warum wird
darüber nicht in großer Ernsthaftigkeit
nachgedacht kann ein anderes Element
nehmen
die Nachfolgeregelung der des neuen
euro-tickets auch hier kann ich nur
festhalten da wird etwas aufgeschrieben
was mit den Ländern bisher nicht
abgestimmt ist der Bund will 1,8
Milliarden zur Verfügung stellen das ist
sogar weniger als für die drei Monate wo
das neun euro-ticket galt wie das
wirklich konkret sein wird seine völlig
offene Frage es wird aber so getan als
wenn es wirklich eine Nachfolgeregelung
gibt und ich bin gar nicht sicher ob
denn die noch vorzustellende Regelung im
Bundesrat eine Mehrheit findet
die Linke denn zur Weiterführung mit der
Atomkraft Stichwort streckbetrieb
also ich finde zunächst erstmal sehr
problematisch dass diese Frage im
Zusammenhang mit dem Entlastungspaket
überhaupt nicht aufgerufen worden ist
ich hätte von der Ampel erwartet dass
sie das Thema Energiesicherheit regt es
gar nicht über Preise selbstverständlich
mit aufruft aber offensichtlich ist aus
Gründen die im Ministerium von Herrn
Harbeck liegen das vertagt worden wir
als LINKE sagen ganz klar ganz klar die
Atomkraft und der streckbetrieb wird
dieses Problem nicht lösen können auch
nicht das Problem der Energiepreise
deswegen sagen wir ganz klar nein wir
sind nicht dafür die Risiken die es gibt
die Frage der Endlagerung ich will es
gar nicht alles aufzählen die bleiben ja
und ich bin einigermaßen
enttäuscht dass eine grüne Partei das
mitträgt wir brauchen andere Lösungen
wir brauchen dringend Energiesicherheit
und wir brauchen bezahlbare Energien
aber die Atomkraft wird es nicht lösen
und was jetzt gemacht wird in der sehr
gespannt sind die drei Atomkraftwerke
sollen wirklich welche reaktiviert
werden das würde mich sehr interessieren
und eines ist klar es wird unsere
deutliche Kritik im Parlament und auch
außerhalb des Parlaments erfahren
Dietmar Bartsch mit klaren Worten zu der
Frage Verlängerung der Laufzeit für
Atomkraftwerke auf keinen Fall hat er
gesagt in wenigen Minuten wird Robert
Habeck das Ergebnis des Stresstests
feststellen ein grüner
Bundeswirtschaftsminister der
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lässt
schwer vorstellbar und es gibt jetzt
auch die ersten Agenturen meine Damen
und Herren das ist so nicht kommen wird
dort wird gemeldet dass zwei von den
drei Kraftwerken runtergefahren werden
sollen und in Reserve bereitstehen
sollen woher dann die sechs Prozent des
Stroms kommen am ersten Januar kommenden
Jahres die bisher von diesen drei
Atomkraftwerken erzeugt wurde ist mir
schleierhaft will man dafür dann ein
zwei neue Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz
bringen und ist das dann ökologisch im
Sinne der Grünen und auch im Sinne des
1,5 Grad Ziels ich weiß es nicht meine
Damen und Herren wir werden Ihnen das
gleich alles übertragen alles weitere
weiß mein Kollege Thomas Bade denn wir
sind jetzt hier fertig auf der
Fraktionsebene Thomas bitte übernehmen
vielen Dank nach Berlin und zu dem Thema
das Sie gerade angesprochen haben wir
werden später in der Sendung nach der
Pressekonferenz mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister auch darüber
sprechen und werden versuchen genau die
Fragen die Sie gerade gestellt haben zu
beantworten aber zuerst geht zum was
anderes zuerst geht es um das dritte
Entlastungspaket Bundeskanzler Scholz
will die Ministerpräsidenten der 16
Bundesländer seine bund-ländergipfel
einladen um über die Kosten für das
geplante Entlastungspaket zu reden die
Ampelkoalition hatte ja gestern das
dritte Maßnahmenpaket als Ausgleich für
die rasant steigenden Preise vorgestellt
dessen Umfang die Regierung auf etwa 65